So now, we have the buzz image.
We know it has a width and height.
Basically we want to use this to give it a numeric representation of this
image in two dimensions.
So we can actually be looking for information in it in the x and
the y directions.
The best way to refer to this would be a now a function I xy which
is a continuous function.
Or if we have a discrete, we'd actually be able to refer to this as I of ij.
So i, j here would be discrete indices, which could be the number of
the rows and the column that we're trying to traverse this thing.
If this was, of course, a continuous function, we would be looking for
variables x and y to be able to now extract the information out of this image.
And of course, one more thing to add here is then basically we tried to
take the resolution of the image, which is represented in terms of width and
height as I showed in the last slide.
Or basically just showing here, very quickly, as to an image basically as
the scope of these images, defined by the width of the number of columns and
the height of the number of rows of this image.